how do you think
social media
has influenced women's standards
and men's oh a lot i think social media
in general just change relationships
because
you're seeing all these instagram models
and it's not real like nothing's real
really
yep and so
that's their like you're at home with
your girl or your man or whatever you're
seeing all these models on that and
they're like they might be liking your
stuff dm and you and stuff so it's just
like
oh i could get that but then
when you meet him in real life it's not
the same so that's that the standards
have just
risen and it's so sad because it creates
a competition between the partners and
there should be no competition
but she'll be like
it's like valentine's valentine's day
people post process stuff oh i've got
this massive teddy i've got all these
chocolates
like
and sometimes it's fake it's not easy
yeah you just put you're just doing it
to prove oh my boyfriend's likes me more
than your boyfriend likes you or
whatever it's like a competition it's
true if you really love it it's like an
ego thing
yeah yes
there we go thanks
of the times of valentine's day that's
when you find out everyone's got a boo
as well
this whole time that you had a man the
whole time literally
crazy the problem is well it's like
people think the
the grass is greener in the other side
you know and then they realize and
they're like [ __ ] it's not and then they
go back and they go back
and they think they can just do it then
you know
i'm gonna give you guys some stats okay
women so oh she's gonna say women what
because a woman so
when it comes to divorce um women file
for divorce 70 percent of the time but
that's and college educated women it's
90 percent
second thing is um
twenty percent of men have access to
eighty percent of women
so the reason that women think all men
are players is because they're all
sleeping with the same ones
the majority one in three men under
thirty one and three men under thirty
yearbooks
proud to be part of that twenty percent
so one in three men under 30 are virgins
um and i'm gonna give you an example so
so for me right i'm 5 11 and a half i'm
close to six foot right i prefer guys to
my height or taller right or close to my
height but let's say i wanted six foot
or taller i'm six o'clock
um that that's only 15 percent of guys
on top of that if you have a specific
type so
you've got a small category to pick
through right so and let's say i want a
guy that makes more money than i do and
is more driven than i am that's an even
smaller percentage so again the reason
like women think men are players is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones
yeah
and
because yeah and then
men are dogs so they'll just sleep with
anyone
so you think so you'll sleep with anyone
no i've got i've got stamina
i'm saying
guys guys will sleep with girls and it's
not it's not a big thing but girls
they're like so selective like as we
should be like i should be but the more
picky we are the unless we find a good
choice sometimes you know sometimes you
are so picky we just actually like
choose the player the wrong one the
wrong one well and then we we get stuck
no you know it's it's our fault because
we have we have the beautiful guy in
front of us and he's giving you
everything you want but you're like
that's not the time well it's because a
lot of times we don't like too good but
we don't like too bad no no it's because
a lot of times attraction cues so the
same the same attraction cues that make
the guy the hero makes him the villain
so you ever wonder why those girls stay
with that guy that's so aggressive and
just hits walls and you're like what is
wrong with this [ __ ] like why are you
still with him it's because like she
knows he can protect her
so like aggression is attractive to us
because the hero has to be a good he can
attack her as well what okay no but
that's that's why you see women stay a
lot of times in abusive relationships
yeah like because like i mean obviously
no girl is attracted to a guy beating
the [ __ ] out of her but that that trait
the that's a masculine trait yes and
like women are attracted to dominance
and you're also attracted to men that
other women want because it's a form of
pre-selection so like back in the day if
you saw a guy that that had a lot of
girls around that that was an indication
that he could take care of them
like social proof is very important to
women in dating like that's why you see
guys with check marks just get like ugly
guys get a little bit of fame they get
they get a model
like that
yeah
so girls always just gonna go for trash
men basically
pretty much no well
it's like a never ending psycho well it
kind of it kind of depends because a
woman a woman would go through phases
so like under the age of like 27
women um tend to go for like the bad boy
the player but as they see their looks
like starting to run out basically
they have to pick a guy
that's a better bet yeah no because like
as women get older like you have less
like um your options
cut in half by the time you're 30 as a
woman based on like dating at bay data i
actually had like a great guy for seven
years
and you wanted to marry me and then i
moved to london and then i met this
he's a good guy but he's toxic if that
makes sense he's a player
and yeah i feel like we are quite
attractive to players because i feel
there's like some narcissist
uh traits on even as women
that we need
to fix
sometimes i do believe like we attract
what we are in a way yeah and if we
attract someone who's a player it's
because you play yourself as well in a
way and you meet that person in order to
fix some narcissistic traits within you
and you guys gonna mirror like each
other you know i do think like have you
ever heard that recently have you ever
met those people that are like in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
after toxic relationship but it's never
them
they are never the problem but there
just happened to be the common
denominator do you know i think that
comes from wanting to fixing people and
thinking that you can fix their problems
i think that's the way women kind of
avoid accountability for their part yes
they ignore their own things and then
they well no no i think women oftentimes
what i've seen is like women will say oh
i'm a fixer and like kind of make it
seem like they're the good one the guy's
the bad one they're just trying to fix
him but really like they have some toxic
traits too and they don't admit to it i
think we all do but don't try to fix no
one like fix yourself it doesn't work it
doesn't work i don't know as women we
are like the nurturer and the the man is
the provider and as a woman like we have
the tendency tendency of like being you
know like smothering you know giving the
love like fixing helping nurturing
but we have to stop with that with men
we have to stop
with our children
cause
they get a tantrum and they get spoiled
and they do whatever and they play you
and then you feel like oh my god i give
so
think where did they much like their car
yeah but that's my mouth oh my gosh but
that's not the that's the exception that
is not the norm oh come on